[Music]
two minutes and 30 seconds of Jax Azize
Luke Perry was hired both by this man
and the director of the movie to mark
how many times this kid sucks at his job
also 1914 Egyptian child labor laws guy
with poisoned drink stalls like a
motherfucker cliche notice this priest
is so eager to get the guy to drink the
poison he stupidly calls for a toast
when there's no alcohol involved and of
course that screws up the plan the guy
wanna drink the water dude damn now all
that hard work you did to get to heaven
is ruin kind of what this guy is a dick
the priest who want to poison him with
Anna's knowledge yeah so wait where the
aliens already on their way here or are
they on standby in case someone
discovers the fifth element secret does
no one want to tell this guy there's a
spaceship outside like a kid with an
iPhone 1914 Luke Perry's first reaction
to the aliens is must record this how
did this species of all their robots and
they look extremely cumbersome if they
were made who make stuff like this and
if there are naturally occurring species
why didn't a churro selection take time
off to let them survive man if they had
said yes what was your next question how
the stones not safe on earth anymore
this kind of microchip finger thing is
required to even unlock the room they're
in well someone needs a sandwich roll
credits bored artist has a gun and bored
artists draw a set gun against obviously
uncuttable wandeling aliens killed the
professor they're monsters I expect the
professor fainted right he didn't drink
the poison so what the hell does a
priest have to explain here did he faint
and I okay so the priest can still stick
the key in the door and let this poor
bastard out right but that's when the
aliens said the evil was good oh
discount Star Destroyer futuristic
keyboards only require a few command
buttons and the letters V and I I have a
different theory to offer you sir we
have 20 seconds one two three four five
six four wasted 30 percent of his
seconds because it is evil
one more reason to shoot first evil
begets evil mr. president
quick throw wal-mart cards at the
absolute evil dinner you hear me does
anyone on the ship hear the president's
ordered other than general does anyone
think it might be prudent to turn the
ship around and blast off at warp speed
while their general sits frozen like
this oh cool the absolute total evil
planet has skull decals for their murder
balls character introduction by way of
sudden waking up from a dream cliche in
case you confused it for South Brooklyn
New Jersey the movie was pretty strict
back in 1914 that something was gonna
happen 300 years later and that's where
we are now but the year is 2260 3
according to this card some 349 years
later I'm beginning to think Luke
Poisson watched and lived the movie
Friday a lot before making this movie
why do you shut the cat out of the
apartment all night but basically lock
it in the apartment all day this plan is
flawed since you have to hope no one is
looking at their security feed while you
walk up to the door not only that but
you'd have to hold this close enough to
the camera for the perspective to be
right but you'd lose light that way
which security cameras need to work you
have 48 hours that's the length of time
it needs to adapt itself to our living
conditions the rapidly expanding evil
planet of fire it needs to adapt to your
living conditions but if evil stands
there Vito plays the self interruption
game so that the president will have to
ask what the hell happens if evil stands
there this space border suggests
everyone in this movie is thinking about
space 2 dimensionally I guess these
assholes waited until the robot people
were about to give the president some
important information before shooting
them down huge ass ship either has no
weaponry or simply never returns fire
either way despite the fact that we
destroyed the ship we expect the cargo
to be intact and survives only one this
statement requires the prominent visual
aids support of my pointy finger the
compositional elements of his DNA chain
of the same as ours
how can you deconstruct the DNA so
perfectly and not know it'll be a hot
check this earth culture has the ability
to rebuild an unknown super creature
from the DNA of a single hand but still
needs any kind of help defending itself
from attack also movie with this
technology we'll go on to try and make
us feel tension at the possible death of
many characters who even if they died
would still have left behind a hand I
might remove 'soon for naked Milla
Jovovich but come on that's unique or
rare told you
perfect yeah you also said he thermal
bandages I don't know what the thermal
bandages do exactly
I'm guessing nothing but he might as
well have said clothing I uh like to
take a few pictures a good pervert would
have taken the pictures before the
thermal bandages that thing's solid I'm
breakable this movie is a lot like
species only with a lot less alien
mating you want out you're going to have
to learn to develop those communication
skills but if she doesn't have
communication skills to understand this
ultimatum despite having been asleep for
a thousands of years and reconstructed
that for a spaceship crash Leeloo
somehow knows how to open this thing
don't you know that wall wasn't solid
how does anything about her so far
demonstrate perfection so the other two
men men oh god the civilization
represents everything evil face
thankfully there was literally already a
flying unit on the scene and 0.8 seconds
away from position when the cop made
this call she drove off what are you the
narrator perfect being does not come
pre-programmed with English 20 damn
seconds of boom bing bada boom bull's
eye relay she's desperate but for all
she knows these words mean killed babies
I've only got one point left on my
license and I need that to get back to
the garage to get the GABA a six-month
overhaul you understand right yes she
understands you one point had been it
reloads so he went from five points to
one on his license when a person fell
from above into his cab which he
couldn't control but then when he
intentionally speeds away from cops that
have tethered his cab he only loses one
point she's your lunch
I wonder where you might go to lunch
thank you so much mcclee which also
korben Dallas warrants the cops by
yelling look out at the same time as
hitting them hey everything is backwards
in this car how did they expect to
follow simple directions
goddammit taxi get in riddled by a
thousand bullets somehow misses both
passengers cool shot but impossible even
if Anakin Skywalker were piloting
looking for a priest the weddings at one
floor down listen Lee Lou told Dallas
Vito's name and he found his address in
a phonebook but he asked for a priest
instead of Vito so this joke could
happen
I am the future is bereft of sandwiches
hey lady wake up she doesn't respond to
one voice command so sure let's kiss her
and none of the cops on the manhunt for
Corbin spotted him his entire trip home
damn none of the cops are waiting for
him back at his apartment those guys are
fucking amateurs she's learning words by
seeing the word and a picture
representing the work but how do you
define words like necessity with one
picture also none of these words is
linked to an accurate picture aren't the
possible suspects kind of limitless what
they originally removed from Earth
because of the threat of theft if
there's precious and powerful as we've
been told then isn't attempted theft
kind of expected it was a man with a
limp came here about a month ago asking
questions about the stones he said it
was an odd and you didn't think that was
suspicious at all also thank God this
priest has a tendency to talk to himself
so we can get some much-needed
information oh really
perfect I know yeah if she got a boob
job said some casting directors this
case somehow survived the crash I guess
that was the plan
causal ship to crash land on earth get
there before everyone else does and hope
the elements didn't get blown up in the
process write down on four parts
undetectable by x-ray that thing is
undetectable by x-ray you can't just see
like that move on like you didn't just
completely reinvent science man there's
no way this gun holds three thousand of
any kind of bullet this guy's
exam type it took the case and didn't
even see if anything was in it even to
verify there's not another case out
there just bring me those stars yeah why
no but why why Mint Hill is eaten up all
the satellites damned evil in the
universe hates HBO come on don't you are
never fully trusted the human race this
information just happens to be real a
while zorg's henchman eavesdrops with
the mechanical roach why would you pilot
your surveillance roach on top of a
blank table where everyone can see it
this guy spots a cockroach but doesn't
spot the cockroach sighs radio tower on
its back wait does this apartment have
blinds but no window you read the
contest why would the government need to
rig a contest to send Dallas to the
planet is it illegal to go there if you
don't win a contest can they not buy
tickets to this divas concert do they
even need to go to the concert to get
the stones
who is it what do you mean who is it the
only person you've ever seen with orange
hair and one you surely knew was in this
cab earlier right we had a bunch of good
luck of a radio and thank God right
because otherwise none of these
characters would have been able to show
up in surprise Corbin had they not heard
about his winning as long before he did
also a military that rigged the contest
only shows up a few seconds ahead if a
dude who heard about it on the radio
whatever is being said on this police
department document was translated from
Sanskrit to Japanese then to English
also they're looking for korben Dallas
but the document doesn't have any
pictures you're thinking a
micromanagement
everything's on final culture they'd
have won but conveniently they don't I
found and Weiss Corbin's d'Or ID on
another door didn't leave rip off this
tag earlier did she go next door and put
it there for some stupid reason what the
fuck don't come back without the stones
unnecessary orders Gor regardless we got
it how do you fuckers know you need
korben Dallas no one told you assholes
where the stones were in fact all your
buddies got blown up by zorg she had to
figure out what happened and why then
somehow find someone who knew that the
stones were on another planet and you
guys are too damn stupid to have
investigative skills like this twice
today today you mean all this we've seen
since she jumped in his cab happened all
in one day I'll take the mission haha
but are they dead and then it suddenly
turned into 1990 how did Corbin get to
the spaceport so fast unless it's part
of his apartment complex he'd need to
drive there and he doesn't have any more
points on his license and no car except
his beat-up taxi that he can't possibly
drive anymore so something crucial is
missing from this equation just think if
they pass boarding they would have been
able to smuggle this ridiculous weapon
onboard our interplanetary flights
pretty liberal about guns the director
and Chris Tucker had an obvious
disagreement about how much Chris Tucker
this character actually required all
these other parties had a huge head
start on the actual korben Dallas and
they all came way too late
also I guess the spaceport sorted out
that massive shooting spree that just
happened four minutes ago because
everything is back to normal so in the
future we somehow revert to the 1960s
era flight attendant who wore skimpy
outfits and couldn't even get the job if
she wasn't smoking huh there are so many
problems with this future that the movie
just leaves unexplored hi
I speak English now right the kung-fu
and mayonnaise was much more important
to learn first but this is I guess this
would be the light year high club then
so here's Vito looking for a way into
the plane and there's not any but guess
what he'll find a way inside that even
the movie doesn't know ha ha
private is this an Austin Powers movie
all of a sudden or what obvious dummy is
obvious by the gears secure I'm just
gonna let this plane take off after an
explosion in the terminal somehow a
growing fiery planet of death that can
make people's heads bleed from
light-years away still needs said people
to retrieve the stones for him do space
shuttles need runways folston paradise
is totally a discount Hawaii our sights
and main ventilation
of course that's Vito who this plane
didn't detect until they got all the way
to another planet movie forces me to
listen to opera as easily as these guys
broke into the divas hotel room and
found the case it's a wonder anyone
bothered with the whole let's pretend to
be korben Dallas plan
none of these assholes goes to get a gun
while she fights hand to hand with these
foot soldier assholes and this guy sees
one of his buddies lying unconscious out
in the hall and figures that Garry
always playing dead during important
missions yeah pull a gun now when it's
way too fucking late hip hopera lone
gunman in this scene conveniently runs
out of bullets he's not done is she
there were other guys behind that guy
she just punched right yeah there were
definitely other guys
she sings one song and gets a standing
ovation each hotel room comes with an
opening in the ceiling so that you can
make a quick getaway first a massive
fight now machine-gun fire is this ship
completely devoid of security through
this stems Eva plays the pronoun game
with Dallas because even higher beings
love the game and all of its challenges
she she she's perfect though right I
mean what sword waits until he gets all
the way back to his ship to confirm if
the stones are actually in the crate
stones Wow luckily a big bullet hole
just got carved in dear abdomen then
also what kind of terror were you gonna
put your entire entourage through if you
didn't get shot okay shows done time to
rip open my stomach and give a white
dude some bricks how did you survive
with four bricks stored in your body how
did you even see
bull's reason to keep things tense is
bullshit Govind Alice's legs are
probably broken the gun dude use the
finger pointed gun sign Jesus movie
don't shoot up oh shoot
this works also the movie never shows
Corman actually climbing on top of the
bar or shows his feet on top of the bar
but it expects you to know that he's at
an elevated position but my head is
still swimming on why the dude lets him
do this this guy stands on this plank
for knowing the reason I can think of a
science that he somehow knows he's in a
movie he survives the bullets and the
two-story fall no problem - 10 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20
21 22 23 one more dude he just took out
half your man and you're still playing
nice also why don't you shoot the walls
this hotel is built with pretty shoddy
materials from what I can tell you could
kill Corbin and get the stones right now
[Music]
does anyone else want to shoot this guy
since he's only one person I will never
understand these monster warrior guys
and their techniques there where is that
does the priest know that is he suddenly
an expert on this space cruise ships
schematics a bomb the lump above of all
these hotels have bomb detectors bomb
detectors only detect arms after 15
minutes of countdown have passed also
bomb detectors have an amazing sense of
comic timing if not actual sensing
danger timing convenient timing ex
machina so the only ship left is the one
closest to the dock entrance bullshit
everyone evacuated before you even
thought to do this you don't know Corbin
is still here and you definitely don't
know its orgas here is there a place
inside the fireball that's safe this
movie thinks so well not the flu vaccine
at least and the paintbrush a few other
things too I think
on your screen finished it so you've
learned about both penis and vagina that
write some very good words envy
vagina vaginal vaginal rhythmic
premature celebration this guy's still
trying to figure out how to get Harry
Potter out of town so that the woman in
black doesn't kill him is steadily
advancing it's moving at incredible
speed why didn't the giant flaming
murder ball go ahead and destroy earth
in the first place it's the only place
where anyone can launch the secret
weapon so why did it bother hiring zorg
to find the stones when it could have
just done this in the first place she
hasn't run across battle murder fighting
or explosion yet also I like how she's
somehow horrified at the footage of war
when she's already lived through the
same kind of yeah seriously you haven't
seen this yet you saw a Tomic bomb on
the first day you went through the
english language why isn't there a rusty
robot missing a key standing at the
entrance Peter how's worst theoretically
yes come on you're a certified priest in
this religion you've been travelling
through space for hours and you're a
certified priest and this religion and
now all that time to look at the stones
a certified breezed in this religion and
only now you're trying to figure out
what to do so what happens now so now
Jesus how many pointless steps are there
[Music]
it's pretty damn easy to figure what the
hell she's talking about even though she
could just have come out and said it
instead of being so cryptic just add
wind just add fire if you played the
band Earth Wind & Fire you'd be 75%
closer to getting the weapon to work but
sometimes they're not available in there
fees are astronomical mine is broken
Chris Ducker is still in this movie only
one of the important thing left cliche
Corbin unnecessarily holds the match up
in the air for a long-ass time so just
like the ancient Egyptians mapped it out
add a dose of love to the secret weapon
and it works trust me somewhere on the
walls in the beginning of this movie
there's a hieroglyph of a dude with his
dick hanging out near the fifth element
SCADA imaging has confirmed the dog
planet dead that's great but isn't it
with the orbit and/or gravity of Earth
and the moon they have children will
they inherit the ability to stop giant
murder planets if you take them to eat
[Music]
I hid this uncomfortable hunk of metal
up my ass two years then after seven
years I was sent home to my family
oh man I gave the watch to you
[Music]
do you wanna get shot speaking another
man to date with your bare hands
maybe that five
there's a red thingy moving toward the
green thingy what red thingy moving
towards the green thingy i think i think
we're the green thingy
[Music]
is it better to be feared or respected
and I say is it too much to ask for both
they wondered if you'd be possible five
five hundred thousand
I thought maybe from one of the smaller
companies when I wanted notice like one
of the cab companies fire 1 million five
hundred 1 million fine sir